we're continuing our discussion around
gun violence that's been reignited due
to the recent mass shootings in buffalo
and uvalde and then a bunch of other
mass shootings just since those two uh
but one of the talking points you'll
hear the most i think you've all
probably heard this whenever a tragedy
tragedy like this happens is
it's not guns that kill people it's
people that kills people
and at a really fundamental level okay
that's true right guns don't fly around
and shoot people
a person has to pull the trigger and
oftentimes in every mass shooting it was
someone who's deranged and has horrible
motivations all of that
i agree to
but
what you and i understand and why we see
that
slogan or that
talking point to be so harmful
is
the person who's already deranged has
those bad motivations their ability to
kill people
and to kill a higher number of people
comes down to how effective of a killing
tool a weapon they have to do that
and so at a basic level i think everyone
understands this right if i say you
absolutely have to be attacked you have
no choice someone's going to attack you
at your home but
you can decide if it's going to be
someone with just their bare hands or
someone with an ar-15 everyone knows
they would choose the person with the
bare hands
so then
you understand then if someone's
deranged and they
have psychotic ambitions to kill people
but they can't get their hands on
something that does that act killing so
well then they're not going to be able
to cause as much
suffering as many deaths as much carnage
so then without changing the hearts and
minds of these people which we should
also try to do of course
but without having to get into that real
complex topic how do you prevent someone
from becoming so deranged
you are
limiting the amount of damage they can
do
so
a great example of this is something
that happened in california a few days
ago this happened at a hospital radio
call went out reporting a person armed
with a knife at the hospital officers
determined that someone had stabbed
three hospital employees swat officers
entered the hospital around 5 25 pm the
fbi was at the scene and offering
assistance where needed
lapd chief michael moore said around 5
30 that officers had cornered the
suspect alone in the area of the
emergency room at the encino hospital
we've locked it down we've isolated the
individual he said so a man goes into a
hospital
trying to kill people he stabs three
people
uh fbi corners him
outcome no one dies
in tulsa if you remember a man went into
a medical facility so these stories are
very similar two men go into medical
facilities trying to kill people one of
them has a knife one of them has a gun
the one with the gun
kills three people the one with the
knife stabs three people and no one dies
so you can see the point that i'm
getting to while of course it is the
fault of the individuals it is the fault
of those two men for trying to kill
people all the blame is on them
their ability to actually enact the
violence and the suffering and the death
that they were trying to
did come down to the type of weapon they
had and so if we can prevent certain
people like those two guys from getting
or at least the one who did get the gun
from getting such effective
killing tools weapons that are designed
to kill as many people as possible
possible we're gonna save lives
and we can do that and why anyone
standing in the way of that honestly
while i can tell you the reasons i don't
understand them like i don't understand
how
appealing to a radical base or appealing
to nra would possibly come above
in your mind in your heart
protecting innocent people from getting
killed in cold blood i
one of the biggest things i'm confused
about is watching the way that certain
republican politicians are acting about
this issue it's disturbing but this
example shows while yes people kill
people
people's ability
to kill a lot of people will come down
to if they can get their hands on a
on something that's designed to do that
or not